[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
a friend to accuse kenosha killer kyle
rittenhouse is himself under arrest on
firearms charges
related to a deadly shooting amid racial
tensions
a court hearing for britney spears as
she seeks to end her father's control
over her finances and tiger king joe
exotic
takes his plea for a pardon to social
media also
my father died a hero trying to save a
family he didn't even know the family of
a repairman who became one of the
victims in a triple murder
speaks to the jury will it be life in
prison or death
for the defendant brandon willie martin
long crime daily covers court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome to blonde crime daily
everybody i'm erin keller along with
brian buckmeyer and terry austin let's
begin
in the midwest where authorities have
filed charges against dominic black an
18 year old they say
supplied the gun used by friend kyle
rittenhouse to shoot and kill two people
during protests in kenosha wisconsin
over the summer the milwaukee journal
sentinel reports that black told
investigators he drove almost clear
across the state
of wisconsin to purchase the smith and
wesson m p 15 rifle written house used
black was old enough to buy the gun and
authorities say he signed paperwork
saying he was buying it for
himself rittenhouse who was 17 was not
old enough
to make the purchase brian and terry are
here right off the top tonight to
discuss this development so terry
my understanding is that this gun
purchase is called a straw purchase
how does liability attach to black when
britton house was the one who pulled the
trigger
well anytime you have a straw purchased
it's when one person buys a gun for
someone who's either unwilling or unable
to buy the gun
here rittenhouse couldn't buy the gun
because he was underage so black could
be liable
because one he either knew what
rittenhouse was going to do
or because rittenhouse was underage and
we know already
that rittenhouse was under age so he
definitely has some exposure here
okay so brian give us some insight into
what black's defense strategy might be
in this case
this is going to be difficult aaron
because really it doesn't matter what
you know or believe the person receiving
that gun to do
so long as you intentionally give them
that gun and the harsh part here is if
they either hur
kill themselves or someone else it jumps
up to what's called an age-class felony
six years in jail i think you've got to
lean into this case and you say hey kyle
renthouse is a hero
and this is a person providing with the
tools to do so otherwise i don't see a
win here so in other words the defense
strategy may be connected to what kyle
rittenhouse is saying through his
attorney's terry and that is
that i acted in self-defense and i was
there to defend other people's property
a lot of people don't buy that but that
is rittenhouse's defense strategy
that's right i mean if that's in fact
what they prevail on the fact that this
was a defense
then you can't associate black with
knowing he was going to quote unquote
use it for a crime
but i still fall back on the fact that
he was underage so that could still be
some exposure i mean the core facts
themselves may be the prosecutor's
ultimate best uh argument in this case
so terry you also have an update on the
ongoing legal battle involving pop star
britney spears for us
well that's right spears is letting a
judge know her relationship with her
father is toxic and she wants him
removed as her conservator
the pop star first had a conservator
also known as a guardian
appointed in 2008 when she was
struggling with mental health problems
her father james speer and an attorney
ran the conservatorship for 11 years
the attorney stepped down in august of
this year and spears said
in court documents that she strongly
objects to her father
controlling her 60 million dollars in
assets
james spears says he's done his job well
taking the estate from being in debt
to being profitable attorneys for both
sides are arguing the matter in a
virtual hearing
that is closed to the public thanks a
lot terry dina dahl is an attorney in
california joining especially now
dina is 11 years an unusually long time
for a conservator to oversee someone
else's financial affairs
this her conservative chip is very
unusual because usually it's only done
for somebody who has
severe mental incapacity somebody's
unable to care for themselves
it's true that she had in the beginning
of this mental health problem
but since then we have seen her perform
in las vegas you know etcetera so for it
to go on for
this long when she is able to kind of
conduct her life
is unusual so terry britney spears at
one point asked for a corporate
fiduciary named bessemer trust to
oversee her affairs
and the court even believes that a
conservator should remain here so why
a company and not a relative so what i
think she's trying to do
is get a trust that will be objective
she's looking for someone
who's not related to her someone who's
related to her might actually have
some biases and might be trying to
influence
and is really if you think about it
self-interested so i think it does make
sense
for her to find a corporation with an
objective purpose
in running the estate excellent point
terry now brian is it time as they say
to
free brittany short answer is yes and as
i'm looking at this now
britney spears has the ability to
articulate who she wants to guide
her finances and her personal issues
with and who she doesn't
she doesn't seem to have an inability to
understand how to take care of herself
or to perform or make money
i don't see what the argument is here
she just doesn't want her father to take
care of her
affairs okay so dina any guess as to why
this case required a closed door
hearing because it was happening and we
couldn't listen and we couldn't see it
well for one thing her father jamie
spears has requested all
along that these proceedings be so
private he said
because the revealing of the information
would be harmful to her and her children
but in this last filing her court
appointed attorney
is asking for more transparency in the
hearings
so hopefully we will start to see that i
mean she seems to actually
be sympathetic to her own free britney
movement
and want the public to hear more about
what's going on here
oh certainly i mean if the movement's
going to help then why not latch on to
it and dina finally for you as well
is it time to free brittany in your
legal opinion
my legal opinion i would say yes but i'm
hedging it was because we have not
had access to these hearings we don't
really know the evidence that's being
presented for the continuing
of this we're only seeing what she's
doing in public and in public like i
said i mean she has these
multi-day tour in las vegas which you
would think somebody with mental
physical capacity could only do that
tour so
like i said we don't have all the facts
but it does seem
like she's doing better and would be
able to start taking care of herself
good insight dina dahl thanks for
joining especially from california on
the broadcast
a colorado judge has declared a mistrial
because of the coronavirus in the case
of a man accused of killing his son
prosecutors say mark redwine killed
13-year-old dylan in 2012.
investigators think the victim found
so-called compromising photos of his
father
and that may have been the motive jury
selection began but ultimately stopped
when the judge
thought he had coveted 19 symptoms he
tested negative but then the defense
said
they too needed to quarantine because of
possible symptoms
the lead prosecutor accused the defense
of intentionally trying to delay the
trial
the court granted the mistrial because
on the or on the basis rather
of ineffective assistance of counsel and
still ahead here on law and crime daily
voters in california making major
changes to a major prosecutor's office
all in the name of justice reform and
later on you remember this guy right the
tiger king
he's making a last-ditch legal effort to
win the attention
of the president
[Music]
let's turn once again now to a number of
criminal justice reform measures which
appeared on the 2020 election ballot
brian buckmeyer you recently talked with
advocates about what some of the voters
decisions mean
yeah so i had the opportunity to speak
with emily galvin almanzo who is the
founder and ceo of partners for justice
here are some of my conversations with
her this week about the decisions at the
ballot box and what they mean
let's look a little bit more at
california because there are two big
things that were also on the ballot box
there that got voted into
first it had to do with the da's uh
prosecution rates in la and then second
the idea of abolishing
mandatory staffing in san francisco not
abolishing the police altogether but
just this concept
of mandatory staffing starting with la
can you kind of walk us through what
california is doing
in terms of police reform absolutely so
we talked about san diego before san
diego 75
or more voters voting in favor of a
civilian review board huge because san
diego county as you know is not
a lefty county it's a pretty
conservative county so you're seeing
conservative movement on policing
just north in l.a you're seeing a da's
race that was in many ways a referendum
on incumbent da's jackie lacy's failure
to prosecute police
the lapd and the la sheriff's department
have had
astonishing like cinematic level police
violence problems
including a gang a criminal gang within
the sheriff's department we're talking
police officers
who have been accused of you know
getting tattoos
for people that they kill so really
really frightening police misconduct
problems
in la county jackie lacy does not have a
history of prosecuting
bad cops that was something black lives
matter la really really been protesting
uh was jackie lacy's total failure to
hold police accountable
now george gascon the newly elected d.a
um
was elected on a reform ticket he's
promised not only to hold police
accountable
but to utilize other tools that increase
police accountability like for example
refusing to call
known lying police as witnesses in his
cases and refusing to rely on
gang database information that it has
been shown to be
dramatically flawed so you've got a new
da who said i'm not going to trust the
cops who lie
i'm not going to trust the information
we know is false and i'm definitely
going to hold bad cops accountable
he beat the incumbent d.a in what was a
a pretty astonishing thumping she had
originally been endorsed by many key
california politicos they all rolled
back their endorsements as gascon gained
popularity
so i think in many ways that race was a
referendum
on on her choices regarding policing and
a demand from the people of la
to increase accountability for police
now up north in san francisco
this may sound like a really boring
measure but it's actually really
exciting
so in san francisco there was a minimum
staffing requirement
a little less than 2 000 cops had to be
on the force at all times
the measure that was passed removed that
minimum staffing requirement and
basically said we only need to hire as
many cops as we actually need
which when you take a step back sounds
pretty reasonable
we don't have minimum staffing
requirements for other positions
the city may grow or shrink like why
would we have this floor for police
because police unions negotiate well
that's why we have that
but what's great about it is in a world
where cities are turning to
more more effective more evidence-based
alternatives you know utilizing social
workers and health care workers
and you know juvenile specialists in
areas where they may be
safer and more effective than using a
police officer
it's really hard to allocate the funding
for that if you're stuck
having this minimum legion of police
that you don't actually need
so what this measure does is give san
francisco the freedom
to hire people who might be better at
these actual tasks
than the police they have on the force
all right
well we'll see how this plays out for
san francisco as well as l.a county it
appears
that the ballot box is where the people
are spoken and that this is what they
want
going forward emily always a pleasure
having you on thank you very much
thanks again brian thanks a lot brian
and when we return here on law and crime
daily a sheriff who handled the
investigation into an infamous ohio
massacre of eight people
returns to court for his own legal
troubles and tiger king's joe exotic
makes yet another plea
to get out of federal prison a legal
plea from joe exotic from the netflix
series tiger king plus a sheriff whose
department investigated
ohio's infamous pike county massacre is
basically
pleading for leniency in his own legal
troubles law and crimes angenette levy
has been following developments in those
cases for us angenette
yeah erin pike county sheriff charlie
reader you know you'll recall that
he's been suspended for more than a year
he pleaded guilty to charges related to
the theft of drug money
seized during investigations by his
sheriff's office
now the charges include two counts of
theft in office and two counts of
tampering with evidence
reader now wants those charges combined
since he says they're similar
and that could reduce his prison
sentence prosecutors say the counts
should stand individually
since there were four separate offenses
related to four different evidence bags
filled with money
the judge has not yet ruled on the
motion reader faces at least nine years
in prison when he's sentenced in january
joe exotic the star of the netflix
docu-series tiger king
says he now has evidence that would have
helped him defend himself at trial
he says that that evidence was kept from
him by his public defenders
his real name of course is joseph
maldonado passage
he was convicted in federal court of
several wildlife violations related to
euthanizing
and illegally selling tiger cubs in
violation of the endangered species act
he was also convicted of trying to hire
someone to kill a competitor
in an instagram post maldonado passage
said he now has
binders with reports from the usda that
state he was allowed to euthanize tigers
using gunshots
he tagged president trump in the post
and said the laws need to be changed
he also wants president trump to issue a
pardon for him
maldonado passage is currently serving a
22-year prison sentence
one of his appeals has already been
denied erin back to you
thanks angeannette and so terry how many
publicity stunts is joe exotic going to
try he had a bust
caravan going to the white house and now
he's taken to social media
i think he's going to try as many
publicity stunts as he can
until he tries to get this you know
overturn or a pardon
so in fact he was convicted one of the
convictions was for you know
shooting five of these tigers in the
head to make room for
other tigers and if in fact this
instagram post
says that there's evidence to say one
agency said it was okay
to shoot these tigers in the head then
he is going to try to get anybody to
listen
and he tagged the president to get the
president to listen so
i think he's going to keep going and do
as much as he possibly can even though
he
is still obviously in jail ever a
showman using unofficial channels this
time so
brian what's the likelihood that he
could successfully snag a pardon or
should he really be worrying about
filing some ineffective assistance of
council claims
yeah so what he's arguing about the
binder that the pro the public defender
had and didn't use evidence that would
have cleared him that sounds like a
pretty clear
ineffective assistance of the council he
probably should go that route i
understand him trying to go for the
partner for president
trump but the likelihood of getting that
is slim to none i would say as the clock
is ticking
70 days and a few hours and counting uh
before there could be a new president
i don't think that president trump is
focused on this case he might be focused
on others
yeah so the legal argument is what we
really need to focus on here
i've got a binder my attorneys didn't
use it and they should have used it and
therefore your honor
i need relief yeah i think that's the
argument that he should be making based
on his his instagram post that seems to
be
a more clear-cut way of getting this
done i again i
i don't think he's going to get the
attention of president trump and i think
the president's focus is on
greater things for him yes joe exotic
though still pressing his case and when
we come back here on law and crime daily
the son of a murdered repairman
testifies
in the trial of the former baseball
player convicted of triple murder
the question now is the punishment
[Music]
a former pro baseball player is now
facing a possible death sentence after a
jury convicted him for committing three
murders brandon willie martin was found
guilty of slugging to death with a
baseball bat his father his uncle
and a security system installation man
the jury must now decide whether martin
should be locked up in prison for the
rest of his life
or whether he should be executed by the
state the state called the family of
barry swanson who was working on the
victim's home security system
when prosecutors say he was in the wrong
place at the wrong time
initially growing up he was in
communications in the computer worlds
he was a in telecommunications he uh was
a
boss did uh he was a site supervisor and
ran
projects in the computer industry and
then later on
he switched over into window coverings
when i was around i think 17-18 and he
had started his own business before
getting into the alarms
i built my whole career around it and i
still do it today with his blessing he
said
he was in orange county doing it so i
said can i do it in riverside he goes
yeah just don't come into my territory
and
i started my own thing and now 17 years
later i'm still doing it how old was
your dad when he was murdered on
september 17 2015.
he was 62. was he looking to retire
yes he only had just a few weeks left
and was going to be just living with my
family and i and enjoying his retirement
and
taking care of the grandkids martin had
been released from a mental health
institution before committing the crimes
on cross the defense asks the victim's
son if he believes the institution bears
responsibility for the murders
not for his actions not for what he did
do you believe that they bear some
responsibility in this case
i think their responsibility is opposite
of what his responsibility is
i don't think that it's relevant
honestly in my mind there is a lawsuit
pending against the county of riverside
and the regional center correct i'm not
allowed to comment on that
is there a pending lawsuit
yes okay and you're part of that lawsuit
correct
that's public record but i'm not allowed
to talk about it
it is pending until he is found guilty
he has been found guilty the defense
asked the victim's
son if he had ever received
correspondence from the defendant's
mother
who was not at home when those killings
occurred
was never approached i was handed a
letter by her nephew michael anderson
and did you have a chance to look at
that letter i looked at it before i
threw in the trash
and was that essentially a condolences
or apology letter from her
uh she apologized for what her son had
done and she
i believe from what i read in it it's i
only read it one time before i threw it
away i was very emotional but i believe
it was that
she apologized for the actions of her
son and she felt he needed to be
punished for what he did
i believe that's what the letter was
entailed to i don't have a copy of it
but
what i read was that he deserved to be
punished for what he did and she was
very sorry for what her son did to my
father
terry what do you make of the trashing
of the letter i'm wondering how it's
relevant to the ultimate question of
life or death here it's not relevant to
that question but what it does show is
that the victim's son
is very emotional and he should be i
mean his father was in the wrong place
at the wrong time
and he was murdered so it's a very
horrendous situation
and in fact you know at the end of the
day this
defendant is either going to get you
know life or death
and frankly because of the mental issues
i think
ultimately he will probably get life in
a mental institution or at least he
should be getting some sort of treatment
i agree with the treatment the question
as to the punishment i'll leave to the
jury myself at least personally terry
you're
allowed to have your own opinions brian
let's talk about
the questions about that mental health
institution because i thought the
defense had every right to inquire into
that
and the witness was stalling it for some
reason
yes and no so can you ask about ongoing
litigation sure you can but i'm not sure
if this is the right witness
both from a strategy standpoint and also
a relevance standpoint
to get into i think they can do that
through other routes
defense attorneys myself included are
guilty of doing this a lot of time and
that's
shutting their mouths this could have
been a situation where the defense just
shut their mouth and said i don't think
this is the witness
to question because there is no one in
this world
who doesn't have sympathy for that
witness and they should just walked away
yeah i was going to say as well brian i
agree with that
this may not have been the right witness
for it you have to handle a
cross-examination like that very
delicately i'm not sure the right tone
was struck
we're out of time here on law and crime
daily we certainly appreciate you
joining us we'll see you next time for
our discussions here about justice
in america
[Music]
[Music]
you